[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry allons
faire connaissance vous avez choisi le
jour à bahia là on est alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois celle en profiter en 2011 le monde
manque pas un petit peu non ah oui et
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france